foreign
[Music]
hey guys tickets are up chrysalia.com uh
Hamilton is almost sold out we got
Montreal Edmonton a lot of Canadian
dates are about to sell out uh Canada
love you
um but they're all I'm coming up on I'm
doing Ohio and I will be also in a bunch
of different places uh so go to
chrisley.com Salt Lake City you know
what I mean figure it out but uh thank
you very much and also welcome to the
next episode of congratulations
[Music]
I woke up in first of all dude like And
subscribe we're moving up dude we are
moving up we're getting subscribers what
the heck is watch that dude what the
hell oh my God no way so good singing I
love the way that guy sings
um but yeah dude that's what's up
um we uh enjoy your viewership and your
uh also your subscription and all that
whatever it doesn't matter but you know
it does matter honestly but really uh I
woke up in a great mood it's really nice
out uh today and I woke up in a gr yo
move hey moods huh how about moods they
just are gonna be up and down and then
you're gonna have a wow day and then oh
all of a sudden something maybe
minuscule will happen and then guess
what boom
boom all of us oh that hurt a tremendous
amount dude wow yeah yes dude I hit my
finger on this side of the
uh microphone and it hurts so bad and it
was that that's honestly symbolic for
what happened because today I was in
such a great I was in such a great mood
and um
I go to I go to get a I go to get a
sandwich I'm with David Sullivan he was
at my house already when I woke up for
some reason by the way no idea how it
happened woke up Calvin was already
playing with him downstairs how'd it
happen he was over last night
we were having a good time watching The
Fly does Delia stop after the fly no did
he watch the fly with Jeff Goldblum yes
he did yes he did he watched it with
Gina Davis and Jeff Goldblum the 1980s
classic the great movie 93 on Rotten
Tomatoes now we don't trust Rotten
Tomatoes but still 93 and deserved it's
a very good movie we watched The Fly
does Dalia stop there
not if there's a sequel
not if there's a sequel now is the
sequel going to be good from the FL
how could it be it was such a standalone
movie now
my buddy Eric Stoltz is in
the Fly 2 name dropping it's fine dude
it doesn't matter he's one of the
coolest dudes
that movie
is a 29 on Rotten to tomato is it weird
to be 93 and then the next one 29 they
must have royally effed up and boy let
me tell you both of them are very well
deserved dude I don't my the worst kind
of
movie I think has the bad guy in it and
for no reason he just doesn't like the
good guy right like it's one of those
things where the guy's just kind of
chilling the lead characters chilling
and then all of a sudden they cut to the
bad guy for the first time and he's just
like he literally has a taser in his arm
in his hand the bad guy in the movie and
he and he says he one day he'll get his
and I'm just like wow just already
doesn't like him
that's such a common thing in movies
period but in the 80s it was so
ubiquitous
um
so I watched that movie with David
Sullivan and here's the thing about
David Sullivan I always watch bad movies
with him he says but it's I asked him to
come over watch The Fly he didn't and
then the next night I had to watch the
fly two he came to watch the fight too
and there's another bad movie that we
watched together and he said why do you
always watch the bad movies with me
and I was like well dude I watched the
fly last night and that's a good movie
anyway dude my point is he was already
at my house when I woke up this morning
don't I guess he slept over had no idea
went up to bed thought he left didn't
leave I guess
so
um woke up in a good mood took some
stuff to the Salvation Army uh or a
Goodwill whatever
cause we had some stuff you know I told
Calvin we had to you know
because his brother's coming this week
we think and um
which is going to be amazing I'll report
to you next week about that and
um
and we took uh we've got like these
extra toys that we were gonna donate and
Calvin was like didn't understand the
concept it was really really cute
so he had like you know because on
birthday party sometimes get this they
get the same gift so he was like
we brought out all his old toys because
we're gonna give somebody the new baby
but then we had to donate some and he
was just like where's Taiwan going and
we were like well you have this already
kind of and we got good use out of it
and we're gonna donate it and we're
gonna give it to another kid so which
one do you want we were having two of
the toys so which one do you want to
keep and he goes like this both of them
more like yeah but it's kind of the same
thing and so we're gonna give one of
these to another kid and he says who and
we and we were like oh you kind of got
us dude like we don't know who so we
were just like a kid in need you know
some some kids don't have toys or don't
have many toys and you have toys and
we're very fortunate and as some kids
don't have toys and he was like why and
I was like ah this is not even I don't
even want to be feeling this stuff at
this point right right because now I'm
sad well because some of the parents you
know they can't afford to now I'm
feeling bad my son just asking why and
it's not even his fault but I'm like oh
we gotta we're just gonna give it away
all right
you got one
and um no but I was like you know we got
to give it away so
we gave him one which one do you want he
looks and he's just like after a long
pause he was just like so like all right
we'll give the red one away so we gave
the red one away anyway I drove the
Salvation Army or no Goodwill
which there is a sign and Goodwill is
cool it's like a g but you'd think it's
just a g for Goodwill but really it's a
happy face and you're like okay
um and so
I drove to get something to eat first I
was gonna meet David Sullivan because he
was taking his car
and I was taking my car you know because
he had his car in my place we drove we
get there and there is a car and now I'm
in a good mood dude I missed a good mood
at this point
I'm Mr [__] I'm walking I'm driving
down the street and it's it's like that
song
messed up what is a big star I don't
know
big stuff
so far Mr Big Star and so
um I I noticed there's no parking spaces
in the except for there's there's
there's there's two parking spaces one
in front of another right it's this it's
on the side of the street with the
parking meters and and all that
and in the middle of the two spaces
there's a car and I'm like wow what a
piece of [__] right
that somebody parked there but then I'm
like you know what
it might not be there that's the worst
thing about parking sometimes you think
when somebody Parks like an [__] it's
their fault but it might actually not be
right it might be the person who parked
before them next to you don't know who
parked first maybe this person next to
them and they may do with the best thing
that they could so really you you don't
get to be mad at that person so we're
going to see someone Park shitty not
only am I mad that someone parked shitty
but I'm mad I don't know who and then
I'm mad because I don't know who what to
be mad at so I've got like this anger
around me and where does it go
it's just kind of in me
so I'm like all right so I don't know if
they Park shitty and then the person
because they were forced to partially
then the person who actually Park should
he left already you feel me so
I drive up to the car and I notice the
windows open and I notice there's
actually someone in the car so now I'm
like okay
piece of [__] is definitely in the car
they could have moved the car but
whatever maybe they're just chilling and
they don't even know that I'm there yet
so I try to park and I realize it's too
difficult I don't want to ding them
because they're straddling the two
spaces right
and I don't want to ding them but I also
don't want them to think I'm gonna ding
them
so I pulled back out I rolled down my
window and I say to the lady there was
two people in the car
one is a lady and the other one I don't
know turns out she's a lady but I don't
know this yet
and I say to her from my car behind me I
say excuse me do you mind backing up a
little bit
and then I hear her say something
and then I I don't but I don't know what
it is so I say I'm asking do you mind if
you back up a little bit and then she
says can you say please
anger
activated all right can you say please
so I'm like
huh
if and so now I'm like wait a minute
certainly
she can't be this big of an [__]
right so I must have been rude
that's the only acceptable reason why
she would say that in my head at this
moment I must have been rude as [__]
but then every wine in my head the last
15 seconds and not only did I say please
move I said do you not only did I say
move I said do you mind moving back a
little bit and then I think wait a
minute she saw me struggling first
anybody who is not even a nice person
but a person
would see someone struggling and then go
I better move back because this is gonna
be uncomfortable for them and me in
effect
so I say
do you mind moving back
then I say it again because anyone said
they said can you say please
and I and then I said
I actually I was really po I was I think
I was polite enough that's what I said
and she said then I'll stay right here
and I said okay but I'm gonna be really
uncomfortably close to you when I park
he says okay
so now one thing's for sure
Park in there
okay
I park it's fine I'm very close to a car
like that close and I walk out and I her
windows open so I say I woke up to I say
hey just so you know I don't know if you
know this but you're taking up two
spaces and people can't park she cut me
off and she said
I don't care
and I said
yeah I understand that but you could get
a ticket you may not care but someone
who's giving a ticket may care and give
you a ticket you have to pay money for
it and she says did I I said I don't
care right
yeah
and I said I'm just trying to help you
out and she goes like this back up
I said okay I'm just back up
and I mean this is exactly how it went
and by the way she's eating like a
[__] piece of [__] like just some
kind of breakfast burrito just eating it
just horse mouthing it you know
and and next to her is another lady like
20 years older than her eating something
else not even looking
it's so weird so I'm like wow that sucks
right
and I'm so you know I
I want to say angry but also I'm like
I'm activated I'm like whoa because you
never know what look I asked her nicely
do you mind moving back because the my
by the way I understand saying please
and I'm all for being polite but if you
say do you mind that takes the place of
please a hundred percent
also she was already being shitty
because she saw me struggling I pulled
it out two times
anyway
but also like I have a tape that plays
in my head where I'm like maybe I'm a
piece of [__] so like I'm walking I walk
across the place I meet up with David
Sullivan who's wearing a [__]
cowboy hat
and cowboy boots like he left my house
without that
I show up to the place he's got blue
like turquoise no teal cowboy boots and
a cowboy a hat so now I'm like oh okay I
left the house in a good mood
hey Jesus Christ you're really testing
me aren't you
not only do I have to do with this
parking situation and the chick
oh horse mountain horse mouth in a
[__] breakfast burrito
and I gotta now I gotta see you know
uh what do you call it uh Brokeback
Mountain at [__] Jones on third
so I so I walk and I'm like man I I I
already judge I'm like I think that was
I say to David I said I think that was
the rudest actually the rudest thing
that I've ever encountered
in my life
like just and I don't mean worst
encounter I've had plenty of way worse
encounters with people but when it comes
to just sheer rudeness for no reason
like I remember one time I told this
story before about I was a coffee man I
went to go to coffee bean in Beverly
Hills and I was waiting in line and this
Beverly Hills lady came in and just
stand stood right in front of me in the
line and I said oh excuse me ma'am I I
um I uh I was in line and she looks back
at me and she goes like she literally
goes like this oh no you were in
like I'm a silly goose
so that was so rude but this was like oh
my God right
so I'm in there and now now I'm I'm I'm
not just activated and like because you
know because I thought like am I gonna
get like if this happened out of nowhere
what the hell else could happen in the
next few minutes without out of nowhere
so I get there I'd say to David exactly
what happened and I'm like what happened
is that okay like was I shitty or
something did I do something wrong he's
like no it doesn't sound like it and so
now and then all of a sudden I get very
sad like sad for this woman sad that
this situation happened sad about how
much her life uh it must be so hard you
know like I don't know you know and then
I'm like maybe somebody maybe she just
lost her father right you never know
what people are going through but then
I'm like man if I just something like
that happened to me I I might snap at
someone but that was crazy but anyway
whatever people are dealing with their
[__] so I'm so upset now I'm and then
I'm so sad for like two hours like two
hours I'm spinning out about this dude I
almost start like like I can't stop
thinking about it I'm emotional about it
I'm like and and I and I wonder if
this lady knew
what my next two hours was like
you know she probably wouldn't give a
[__] but it just was so wild that people
were so dude it was so weird you know
what she was like the [__] bad guy in
the beginning of the fly too for no
reason she just didn't like me
just insane
so then
I texted Kristen about it and she's like
oh that's okay you know she's like don't
let people derail you from you know your
your journey and your your happiness and
I'm like yeah you're right and so I was
like so what do you want me to pick you
up something and she wanted me to pick
her up something I go to the counter the
[__] place and they're like sorry the
power went out we don't have anything
for sale anymore so I'm like oh Jesus
Christ so I went to another place I got
her some [__] I walked into the sweet
greens and the guy dude I had on these
[__] this is what I'm dressed like
but I also got the tattoos I'm yadded up
and the necklace and it's ridiculous my
sunglasses Whoopsie Daisy they're red
and I got [__] cargo pants that don't
flare out at the end but they sure as
hell don't tighten up and they got
splotches of white paint on it and the
[__] Yeezys with the matching socks
to the shirt and dude yeah I'm dripped
out but I'm not thinking about it I
ordered something in sweet greens and
the gay dude behind the [__] that isn't
even helping me he goes like this hey
man I really like your style and I'm
just like bro you know what we'll move
it up
[Music]
made me sad and then immediately made me
happy but then I'm like hey Chris
what are you doing letting people
dictate your mood
hey Chris what you doing letting people
accept you're not accept you you're
doing making it so that that affects the
rest of your whole day ah what you doing
me
hey me be happy on me
work your [__] as best you can work your
program keep your side of the street
clean best you can just do it let random
people make you feel better or worse for
hate me children
I gotta get over this [__] man I gotta I
gotta just like you know and [__] this
so I'm not trying to be a self-help Guru
but man you gotta let people this is why
I say grow or die dude you gotta [__]
work your [__]
and you gotta help as much
man I was talking to my wife last night
and she was just like
she was like what do you want in life
and I was like I want to be a great
family man and everybody around me
that are close friends and family to
respect me and love me and she was like
you're not gonna get that unless you
feel good about yourself and love
yourself and I was like God mother
[__] no don't be saying that stuff
dude I know it's true but also don't be
saying it at 1am
[Laughter]
after the fly two don't be saying it
because it's like dude yeah but
you know what I mean
oh dude you trying to activate me
sweetheart
oh boy
life's crazy huh
so you just [__] take the good with
the bad but you can't let it affect you
and then it's like [__] God damn it
why was she so rude
that's nothing to do with me right
but this is what we talk about now and
now you all know about me and what I
think and all this [__] and it's like
okay I'm gonna have this podcast
nobody's gonna know everything about me
on my internet
okay cool everyone's gonna know
everything about me
the girl I'm gonna know about um
[Music]
now we're gonna talk about everything
and everything goes on yourself I got to
talk about conversation
and everybody knows and they're gonna
make a clip of this and oh and the
clip's gonna not only is the regular
podcast gonna get used but the clip's
gonna give you some I know everybody
knows
and then I gotta [__] go on Instagram
and say oh a bunch of blue check mark
[__] guys are liking my [__] I'm like
wow that's amazing then I go find out
that everyone bought them
[Music]
and why do I even give a [__] about that
dude hey what's up hey hey blue check
hey what you doing having 648 followers
getting verified
what you doing being a [__] licensed
massage therapist get in the [__]
blue check mark it helps business okay
dude you know what helps business
business
laughs
you know I mean you know what else can
business hey you know it helps business
business dude okay
not changing the color next to your name
right
you're buying blue check marks for 11 or
15 a month I don't know how much it is
whatever how much it is it's too much
and I put the freaking clip on uh
Instagram dude the thing went dummy
viral and everyone's [__] getting mad
at me also loving it dude I'm gonna tell
you how the [__] it is that's it dude
I've got nothing left I will tell you
how it is
if you buy a blue check mark maybe maybe
if you're something like
a photographer
or if you're
a plastic surgeon
okay
but hey
are you Johnny
don't get
hey
are you Bill
hey guy
keep the eleven dollars hey
hey
are you Nicole hey Nikki
keep the eleven dollars
hey are you Hank
Hey how
Lisa keep it
we're good
you helping your business ah
I mean it's just so ridiculous these
people buying you cudas man Instagram it
made so much money off the [__] I want I
want to buy I want to buy I'm gonna I'm
paying to have my blue check mark
removed
bro here's what they should do they
should make everyone buy this is so
gangster and if I was this is why I
don't run the [__] this is legit why I
will never be as big as I possibly can
because I would do [__] like this if I
was this is why I'll never be in charge
of anything dude if I was Instagram or
Facebook or whatever the [__] it is Mark
Zuckerberg Zuckerberg Zuckerberg
I would get everyone to buy the
Instagram and then whoever bought the
Instagrams
I would one day change them all green
and they were all be they would all be
exposed so you got licensed massage
therapists just like this
oh no
all of a sudden Lisa is just at the
sorority house just like oh wait what
I don't understand it
I get it though we all want to be
accepted right that's why I was upset
with the [__] lady at the car that's
why I was up that's why I was happy when
the [__] gay dude at sweetgreen said
I would love my style dude I still think
about that [__] boy it makes me buzzing
I don't know dude everyone wants their
extra [__]
their share I don't know
I don't know we all search for
validation in certain ways
and I did it through having sex okay
all good all good
deep dive into my psyche oh good oh good
um but yeah
this is this is it dude you guys are the
you guys who support this show are
really rocking man really really rocking
the show's been on I don't know four
years five what has it been who cares
what does it matter but my thing is like
And subscribe and my thing also is wow
dude this show is the hardest hitting
you know we don't we don't talk about
politics we talk about the hard-hitting
issues dude blue check marks and parking
spaces that's what we do dude
until we all I need someone to help
build this [__] log cap dude here I
got the [__] blue I got the the
blueprints right there wow looks great
dude I'm [__] good look at the way
how gaded up I am Jesus Christ should I
get it all done my whole body I'm gonna
get a [__] Batman Insignia on my
chest and just a water slide from the
middle of my chest down to my penis
that's disgusting
[Laughter]
um so anyway dude
what's up with this [__] God it's so
what it's illegal to be in Canada and
say something about
trans people or what I don't know you
know anymore it's like they were just
like you can't now you can't say I don't
dude you know what's also you know
what's violence violence here's the
thing that our violence is stabbing
someone choking someone shooting someone
smacking someone you know
hey saying doing this hey [__] you
that's not violence okay now granted
there's a sliding scale all right if
you're out there trying to incite a mob
yeah I don't think that that should be
legal hey come on let's get him that's
that's violence hey look at those people
who aren't dressing the way they should
look at the people whose color aren't
the aren't aren't a shade to my liking
get them that's violence that's the kind
of non-silence that's violence but the
second you just are silent that's not
violence silence is violence no
not silence isn't violence either that's
how much you know silences in violence
silence and not they don't want you to
be talking and they don't want you to
not be talking
no matter what you're doing violence
right that's basically what they're
saying in Canada because it passes rule
to where if you're around like a hundred
meters at a Tran if there's like more
than three trans people together and you
say something
against trans people you go to G you get
you go to jail or get fined or something
yeah
and I'm just like okay
so look you talk about free speech and
all this [__] fine you know free speech
and people are like
you know they're taking free speech from
us dude it's gone already it's it's gone
they don't have free speech in Canada
now I am on tour in Canada coming up in
September October whatever the [__] I'm
gonna go out there and I'm gonna [__]
let them have it the way I do all right
I don't dude I won't I would never know
I would never
right I'm sure it under the Arts it's
okay and it's not like we're doing a big
trans rally and by the way I love when
God love trans more than regular people
I love them more than regular people
um
it's it but it is
hilarious how at the [__] thing they
were like uh a bunch of uh they were
like having a political rally and they
were like because we think it's violence
if they say that and they're like behind
them it's like it's it why the the the
people that they pick uh the of the
trans people to represent the thing it's
always they're always it's always they
look like The Fifth Element you know
it's like I I or or uh uh Rainbow Bright
and it's okay even if a a chick that
identifies as a chick that dresses like
this you you'd be like whoa but if you
say whoa because you know they'd be like
that's violence you're like all right
you know how about this too much makeup
is a lot right you know and uh I don't
care if you're a guy or a girl or
identify as a guy or a girl but I'm a
bully right because I'm saying this and
I know the other thing is I know that
most people agree with what I'm saying
but okay they're gonna limit my ads
because I said this or whatever it is
but the whole point is they is that not
taking the Free Speech away they took it
and
I you know I understand too like you
can't say certain things on YouTube you
can say certain things on Instagram
saying certain things
that's definitely a slippery slope
because if they you know they are
companies and they can do what they want
the second you start caving to things I
do think though that some things like I
don't think you should be able to say
whatever the [__] you want on certain
platforms because it's definitely leads
to
deaths
but you know
I don't know
I guess there needs to be a better
system figuring out what the violent
things to be said are right
I I you know I look like I said the
reason why I'm not in charge anything is
uh
is because I would do the blue check
mark thing and make them green one day
but you know I just I'm everyone's so
mixed up man I feel like the trans
people who are truly trans that are like
I'm a woman
and but were born biologically a male or
I don't know how to say without getting
in trouble but that they are even like
oh God can we just
can you stop guys
I just want to be a woman and I am a
woman and just chill
right
or maybe I'm wrong
um who knows what I do know is there's
no free speech in Canada
um that's crazy right
uh
uh they announced their Coachella
lineup
let's look at it because it's always
good for a laugh
wait a minute
okay Coachella
is this it here we go
this is just this is always good for
laugh
because I'll tell you why because
wait a minute
wait did they announced the Coachella
recently
wait what did he say oh I think he was
telling me Stagecoach
no he just sent me
stagecoach's lineup is out please do
that again
he said it Wednesday Stagecoach
Hardy texted me
coach and he said please do that [__]
again
um yeah I guess it just came out I mean
he would know
God damn it here we go oh yeah yeah it's
so good when you do this because
it's it's so it's the whitest [__] in
the world it's just incredible dude so
this is 2023 here we go yeah it just
came out
I don't know either way let's do it
so it's amazing this is what's amazing
is the drop off of people that I know to
then immediately you know how like
sometimes you're like who's in that
movie and they're like yeah it's [__]
Hugh Jackman and you're like oh yeah
know who that is and then uh Julianne
Moore and you're like oh yeah I know who
that is and then they're like and then
genre no and you're like uh yeah I know
that guy that's the guy from the
professional right like yeah and then
they're like yeah and then uh [__]
flimbot Nanny Checkers is is in it and
you're like oh okay well I don't know
from flimbot Nanny Checkers to whoever
the [__] is in the movie I'm not gonna
know who it is all right
and uh
and that and and it in the movies it'll
be like three people
but then this and in Coachella it'll be
like there'll be like 10 artists you
know and then they'll be like by the way
we also have [__] smash Kitty and
you're like never heard of them
Stagecoach goes from the guy I know to
the next person is a [__] goddamn
made-up name of that an AI that you
typed in white country singer to and uh
and and just put it in AI
so here we go Friday Luke Bryan
know who that is from the acclaimed song
doing my thing from the mo from the
important
historically important song aptly titled
doing my thing
from the Smash Hit
doing my thing Luke Bryan from the most
not only
regular
name but regular looking guy
and regular Luke bro the kind of guy
where that has the music when you walk
in a Target and it's playing and you
don't even realize it
you know I'm talking about that kind of
music right that's the kind of Luke
Bryan That's the kind of music Luke
Bryan does you're shopping at Target
they're playing the whole discography of
Luke Bryan and you're just like oh look
they got these shorts and you're not
even
yeah I might buy a humidifier and it's
just doing my thing and you're not even
you know you don't have a clue it's even
being plain
okay so Luke Bryan
and then the drop off is incredible
and I'm not saying fame or look I I
don't let me just be clarify I don't
know these people that doesn't mean
these people are less than
I am firmly saying I'm not the cool one
here I don't know who these people are
because I'm not involved in this cool
culture where people go
and the you know the chicks walk into
the [__] thing and they're just like
and the guys are like classic I'm not in
the cool crew
okay
Luke Bryan
who's doing his thing
then immediately John party and Riley
green okay so why
Riley
and then the nerve of it to be green
afterwards right so white there's never
been someone with the last name green
that isn't white by the way
then ZZ Top okay cool I know that yeah
occasionally the pepper went in L King I
think I've heard the name then we go
brieland
could be an amusement park
Amusement about cheese have no idea
welcome to brieland here's some Gouda
enjoy the Swiss cheese train
then there's Melissa Etheridge of course
I know her okay because it would be
absolutely a hate crime if I didn't then
here we go and that this is when it gets
good
Priscilla block
huh
Priscilla block daughter of Mark block
Mark block here
okay so Priscilla block then Sammy
Kershaw wow this is this is already
goddamn hilarious how does it happen
then Ian munsick
dude and then Nate Smith
dude it might as well book hey dude you
ever heard regular normal oh who's that
oh just a guy one guy his name's regular
normal
what's he saying honestly just notes
oh yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's [__]
regular normal these guys look like they
listen to Luke Bryant and they go too
much
no no no they go to Target they're like
we gotta get out of here I hear Luke
Bryan dude after Nate Smith dude what
Jackson Dean that's two white guys
that's how white that one is then
Trixie
Mattel
[Applause]
[Music]
Mattel such a white
company
and Trixie dude
that would be like if your name was
[__]
Daisy the Gap huh
is that my producer showing me a picture
of Trixie Mattel
oh that's a drag queen right whoa
moving on
whoa dude I mean her face you know
whoa so much makeup dude Timber Tim
Burton movie so uh all right then after
Trixie Mattel
what are you kidding me
Seaport Seaforth so why dude dude white
people love this C you know just being
out there Seaforth then Drake Milligan
dude what on Earth is I I I continually
am astonished at these [__] names
every year
there oh
I do it
Americana
Aquarium
that's the whitest what's wider than an
aquarium and then American Aquarium holy
[__] [__] dude
oh my God American Aquarium
and then Nordic Razor scooter just
kidding that is so unbelievably White
welcome the whitest band since
American Aquarium
Nordic Razor scooter and then just loose
leaf paper just blows up and it goes
another
against the thing
yeah like a good little guitar playing
like oh my oh this is [__] insane
dude are you kidding me they're [__]
with me now
flaming groovies oh dude German exchange
students hello we are the Flaming
groovies
we do country in Germany too
oh
then the last Bandoleros okay that's
definitely not white Tiara Kennedy
Mackenzie Carpenter Bella white bro
White's in the name that there will not
be Saturday April 29th cannot top that
in whiteness okay let's go Kane Brown
already first one don't know who it is
now remember that's on me Old Dominion
white Gabby Barrett white Brian Adams
know him Nico Moon Nelly even the black
guy has a white name
Nelly
that's the name of a babysitter
then Morgan Wade okay
Mary Stewart
and the fabulous superlatives wow Mary
Chapin Carpenter know her Cameron
Marlowe Nikki Lane Corey Kent Lily Rose
Restless Road Cooper Allen
Adriana Jamie Wyatt Keb Mo isn't that a
that's a black guy I think treybert
Logan Ledger bro these are unbelievable
let's go to the last one here we go
Chris Stapleton obviously I know who
that is Brooks and Dunn know who that is
Parker McCollum gone I'm gone right
there Parker McCollum no clue Tyler
Childers saw white Turnpike Troubadours
Diplo I know Diplo
that's not country I guess you could
probably do some country [__]
Laney Wilson some of these names are so
white I feel like they were already in
it maybe they weren't Ryan Bingham
Parmalee Bailey Zimmerman Luke Grimes
Valerie June Warren ziders I mean dude
Sierra Farrell 49 Winchester Tyler
Braden dude
Madeline Edwards Caitlin butts
the next one Nick shoulders dude just
body parts
Caitlin butts Nick shoulders Kimmy tits
and Guy [__] balls
dude after that featuring Guy Fieri
Stagecoach Smokehouse of course
oh my God
this is crazy dude
this is just insane
it's the way to [__] on Earth
wow
okay
how does it how they continually outdo
themselves
and headlining a Kleenex
wow dude I got sweaty doing that that
was a funny thing
hahaha
I gotta blow my nose let me take a break
all right I'm back I had to blow my nose
yippee dude um
what's up I forgot about this and I
definitely wanted to talk about this my
producer just reminded me what is up
with
uh
uh hey darling
sup
this guy
first of all
look at this article
what is the Dalai Lama apologize for
asking a young boy to suck his tongue
it's gross hey
bottom line gross
the Dalai Lama is a positive for kissing
a young boy
on the lips and asking him to suck my
tongue
after a video of the in incident spark
outrage on social media the 84 87 year
old Buddhist hey also he's too old to be
out you know
like just when I'm when I turn 60 I'm
indoors for the rest of time just
it's 87.
uh
the 87 year old Buddhist priest regrets
the incident and wishes apologize to the
point of his family as well as his many
friends across the world for the hurt
his words may have caused
oh his Holiness often teases people he
meets and I mean his Holiness you know
hey it's 2023
his holiness
to imagine being okay with being called
imagine being someone hey who's holding
this you know you're not get the [__]
out of here with that [__]
um
he often teases people when he meets in
an innocent way and pray my true fell
off [__] I gotta get it
sorry guys my shoe fell off
um
wow he's making a I love how I love how
not even comedians are just being like I
was joking
um a video of the incident shared widely
on social media shows a young boy
approaching dilemma during an event
asking him for a hug okay the leader
calls him on stage and motions to his
cheek
saying first here
according to life visitors from the
event the boy obliges in the development
there's a hug
then continues to holding on to the boy
the leader then motions to his lips
I think here also that's a creepy uh
uh the audience laughs and applauds
uh
the Dalai Lama poison ads and suck my
tongue
okay you know
I love how the the Dalai Lama is
probably dude he should that's hilarious
wow I mean you know
how is this
is this is a real video that they have
of it
foreign
the weirdest part was how long it took
him to say it
ow
I mean
oh my
Okay so
actually that's weird
hey guy oh dude that's so weird honestly
what is who's the [__] Dalai Lama by
the way he's you know ever since he's
like wearing that [__] maroon and
gold [__] like he's a Spartan did he
just [__] floating around you know
just doing this [__]
and people are just like oh there he is
what's he do he's a priest a Buddhist
priest ah it's all good man I have a
podcast
dude I would have to I'll only have a
guess if it's the Dalai Lama
yo what's up dolly
hey dude you know what you're my
favorite Dolly it used to be Dolly
Parton but now after your audacity and
the way you keep wearing the same [__]
every day I think that's awesome pretty
much only you and Steve Jobs did it
uh and Ronald McDonald the Dalai Lama
has long sat the center of controversy
as a principal leader of the of the
Yellow Hat School of Tibetan Buddhism
the Dalai Lama is among the best numbers
uh
followers of the spiritual sect believe
the current dialogue
tends oh it's a different guy always
wow like Batman
to be The Reincarnation of his 13
predecessors
it's not though
um
wow
dude he said Europe belongs to the
Europeans which is hilarious people got
mad at that even though if you're in
Europe you're you're European unless
you're visiting and then it doesn't
belong to you and then the following
year you apologize for telling the BBC
in an interview that she should have a
female success for
a successor and she should be more
attractive wow that's gangster I love
how the Dalai Lama in his head for sure
even though he's saying like oh I
shouldn't have said that he's for sure
like for in his head he's like I'm just
I'm old school you know
yeah I don't even wear a belt you know
like I just I honestly would expect I'm
I'm
I I wear curtains I'm old school
God what a bunch of what a waste of time
this only the Dalai Lama has spent a
lifetime advocating for Tibetan autonomy
and has taken steps to ensure that the
mission doesn't die with him that's fine
though he has dreams of living to 113
you know okay why there
he plans to consult with his advisors
around age 90 for instructions about
finding a successor
well I still got 23 more years huh
that's crazy
look guys I know I plan on living to 113
not a day later but
when I'm 90.
if I start asking kids to suck my tongue
that's when we start gotta we gotta
really kind of
you know that they're gonna have the
meeting they're like look we know we
said 90 but I feel like
ah where's the Matthew McConaughey thing
did you put that on there
oh really
that's weird you can't link it
let me play it I got it on Instagram
we all want to be in
the 785
a song a song a song
a song
[Music]
we're gonna talk about
and how to get in it
we're also going to talk about said
nothing
and the red line just talk about traffic
only
talking about driving
and some others uh wow got to the black
guy and he said and some other services
you gotta do is click the link and
reserve your spot before it's too late
it is only going to be happening once
I want to see you there
he said it's only going to be happening
once and held up four fingers
The Art of Living
I'd like to invite you dude only talk
about traffic
you know a lot of people want to drive
in the left lane traffic just Cruise you
know what I mean but we gotta talk about
those other four lanes right we got to
talk about the mother Lanes you know and
we might talk about the other lane we
might even talk about taking an exit you
know you got to pay the traffic signs of
course and traffic lights and that's
cool man that's great to be the traffic
lights because you got to be you got to
stop at red so the other people can go
and it's it's two-way street man you
know and not only do sometimes treat
Streets Run perpendicular but they're
also uh what do you call the other one
where they cross each other right
whatever the [__] that's called I can't
remember and but you know what man
sometimes you're in a car and a person's
another car man you got a park you gotta
park next to each other and the parking
person you understand Park [__] up you
got to be like we back up and she'll be
like get [__] say please you know you
get mad you know and it's all good the
Art of Living
that's it for YouTube if you want the
uncut the raw the edited the unedited
sorry version uh of the show go to our
patreon patreon.com
patreon.com crystallia that's where you
can get for just six bucks the whole
episode and then also you can get uh the
rest of the episode there's one extra
episode a month for the patreon and you
can get that and the link to our Discord
and all that stuff for just six bucks
but uh I think we have like 26 episodes
now there that aren't on YouTube they're
just on the patreon so you can go watch
them all now thank you very much
patreon.com crystalline
[Music]